[Music]
so chuck i got more to tell you about
the moon
okay we did a whole explainer on
moonlord and that was fun but i'm not
done
good okay i'm all about it
the moon is so mysterious for so many
people for so many reasons and it's
so i mean and it's so romantic yes it's
almost everything it's all of the above
it's spooky and romantic spooky romantic
it's poetic in many respects yes yes you
know it's in so many paintings like
you know
yeah and and it's it's it's a it's a
fundamental
part of the symbol for islam there's the
crescent moon with christ
with venus in the sky next to it so yeah
the moon is important
and
so a couple of things uh there's an old
saying i know that was venus well okay
it's an evening or morning star right
if it's bright it's generally going to
be venus right but the
um
it's it's rare that there's another
really cool star next to it and venus is
always in the sky
either with the
waning crescent or the waxing crescent
so typically that's venus in practice
it's venus and by the way it's really
cool to see it when
it's a certain time of night and it
really isn't quite like all the way dark
and it's
called twilight chuck oh use the word
do you call it when it's night but not
quite dark
did i just invent something
and you know there's this stuff
around us at all times that you know it
goes in your lungs and you push it out
and that big yellow ball
that gives us light
that i'm so glad you woke up today yes
out of your
40-year coma yes
yes but twilight
venus at twilight is i mean it's and and
you can see it with the naked eye and
it's like it really looks like somebody
turned on a light in the sky yeah yeah
and and a little known fact because
venus orbits the sun
closer than we orbit the sun
okay
venus will never
stray too far away from wherever the sun
is on the sky
it's not going to end up behind us with
the sun in front of us right it's going
to be near the sun
so that's why
you'll typically notice venus just after
sunset
in twilight or just before sunrise
so in evening twilight so dusk
and then the poetic other side of that
would be dawn right
cool yeah okay so more about the moon
uh all evidence suggests an all
theoretical understanding of the
formation of the moon helped by the way
by rocks we brought back from by the
apollo program to study and look at we
get a sense of the origin of that place
you guys remember that that's why
america was great
when we did stuff you know because we
didn't mind our tax dollars being used
to make us the greatest nation on earth
we're just saying
done yet you know
go ahead so we brought back rocks and
we've and we were able to yes analyze
them and realize that the moon doesn't
have much iron in it okay and an object
that size should have much more iron in
it than it does
so how do you make a whole object that
has hardly any iron
so you make it out of a
out of a collision with earth
but it sideswipes earth after earth has
already sunk its iron to its core
right
so when earth was molten
heavy stuff falls to the middle light
stuff floats to the top gotcha compared
to iron rocks are light so all the rocks
floated and the irons sunk iron nickel
gold cadmium all the the heavy elements
they're down here in the core okay so
now earth has pre-sifted the elements
pre-sifted now you have a a mars-sized
impactor that side-swipes the earth
scattering earth's crust into a ring
around the earth
that mars size impactor keeps going but
the debris mess that it left
continues to orbit the earth
and the slightly larger bits of this
have more gravity than the slightly
smaller bits
so they'll attract more objects and they
get bigger and as they get bigger they
have even more gravity and they get even
bigger and bigger and it's a runaway
exponential growth
the big get bit bigger and the little
ones get
eaten eaten thank you
[Laughter]
so
we think over not much time a matter of
months if not only just a few years
earth
had a ring not much unlike not not
unlike saturn and that ring coalesced
into the moon and that moon was 20 times
closer in the sky than it is today oh
wow well that must have looked beautiful
yeah so imagine that just imagine that
or it's 20 times wider imagine like moon
rise yeah that's that's very star wars
you know like
you're standing there in the desert and
you see like you know
a giant
boar in the sky and you need music to go
with that and that would just totally
complete the scene
so
it turns out
tidal forces
are very sensitive to distance
very sensitive in other words not
emotionally sensitive but if you change
the distance by a little bit
it'll have a much bigger effect than
you'd otherwise think on the strength of
the tides okay now i can't get over
thinking about emotionally sensitive
tidal forces
where all of our oceans are just like
where you go
what did i
do what did i do
you said it's you it's not me but i do
did i deserve this
right
you're just gonna throw away everything
we had
as you slowly drift away
you're so distant i don't understand
why we don't communicate anymore
you're so distant all we have to do is
talk why are you so distant
there's a space between us
i don't know how to fill this chasm
between us
i can't do all the work here okay
i'm earth and i can't do all the work
chuck how many hours of therapy have you
been in with your wife
oh god
by the way i'm the one saying that in
therapy not here
so
so so
mathematically because you can be
mathematically sensitive okay i just
want to broaden your use of the term
sensitivity so
the moon
uh the the mathematical sensitivity of
tidal forces goes as the cube of the
distance oh sweet okay
so in other words if it just went as the
distance okay
if it was like 20 times closer then the
tides would be like 20 times higher than
they are today
but no
does it go as the distance squared
that would mean the tides would be 20
times 20 higher than than today what's
20 times 20 oh i don't know 400.
don't you pull out a calculator you're
on this show you're going to tell me
what 20 times 20 is
no i'm not doing it
okay you got 400
however
tidal forces go as the cube
of the distance
so the cube is you multiply by itself
three times so 20 times 20 that's 400
times another 20.
so 400 times 20 that gets you eight
thousand
so
the tides the oceanic tides on earth
raised by the moon when the moon first
formed
were 8 000 times
higher
wow than they are today
look at that and and and and look at
that we're trying to get back there with
global warming that's wonderful that's a
different problem yeah tell me about it
okay so now watch what happens tides
sloshing
on and off the shores there's friction
between the solid earth and the moving
water
okay and so earth's rotation back then
was actually faster than it is today all
right depending on how far back you you
go you get like an 18 20 hour day
for earth not 24 hours look at that okay
so we have a big moon higher ties faster
rotating earth but the tides are so
ferocious earth is slowing down oh man
because of it
and in response the moon's orbit is
increasing it is spiraling away from the
earth
cool and it has been doing that ever
since
we still have sloshing of tides on the
shores earth's rotation rate is still
slowing down the moon is still spiraling
away from the earth
but much slower than it once was
why are you killing me softly if you're
gonna leave just leave
i don't understand
oh by the way
we
had tidal influence on the moon
okay the moon at one time rotated like
anybody else in the in the in the solar
system you see the front side the back
side the left side the right side
but our tidal forces on the moon slowed
its rotation down until we
locked it
we locked the moon's rotation around the
earth that's why i'm leaving
because see you only see one side of me
i'm a complex person
but it seems like you know when we're
together i can only show you one face
check i
this sounds like a tv series
why don't you just go
why must you make it so torturous i've
been drifting from you for all these
years
you didn't feel me drifting away
i mean seriously
chuck you can't make a hole
oh
psychological relationship
hey you know what this show is called
as the world turns
[Music]
[Laughter]
authentically it'd be the best name show
there ever was ever
okay oh god that may be the stupidest
thing i've ever done on this show
it's okay
okay so so the point is we tidally
locked the moon because we have stronger
tides on the moon than the moon has on
us
and so moon just got locked we slow down
its rotation locked in on it it only
shows one face to us
and the other face we've never seen
until we orbited it with spacecraft the
moon is trying to do the same thing to
us he wants to slow us down so much that
we
only show one face to the moon and the
day that happens we will be in what's
called a double title lock nice
that's a nice dance i like it yeah yeah
so that's so that's what it looks like
chap hey man that that's great
that's not moon lore that's just to the
moon facts hey listen that is that is
awesome i mean
at the moon and the earth
locked in a dance so i have to repeat my
one perfect sentence that i've ever
written in my life okay may i repeat it
for you please okay
the rotating planets
orbit the sun
like pirouetting dancers
in a cosmic ballet
choreographed by the forces of gravity
wow
damn
[Laughter]
oh
okay
all right
chuck we got to end it there okay enough
of them we'll give the moon a rest okay
okay and the earth moon family
exactly we'll lead them to their drama
all right this has been an explainer
video keep looking up
[Music]
okay bye bye do you know what the name
of our moon is
oh
no the moon how did that happen yeah
yeah everybody gets these great names
and we and we have
moon moon no no it has a name it's
called luna
oh that makes sense and and and and
that's funny because in certain
languages they call it luna yeah luna
and earth has a name
okay
earth it's called terra
oh yeah okay and we're called terrans in
most sci-fi films oh yes we are yes we
are called terence and the sun has a
name
okay
it's called soul sol
nice yeah so if you just latinized
everything we have salt tara and we have
luna you got all the planets and
everybody's one happy family of cultural
expression and diversity
awesome